first manipulate still a connection
because it's hip shoulder connection
that batters
[Music]
he's gonna move and that's where I
stepped in
that's right
hey run it in which way is it going is
paste in it right now which way to go
out very similar here a lot of you look
here and then you're done now you're a
robot you want you want to be spiraling
so you can see it's here and I'm going
to turn inside of that let me see it now
[Music]
but what happens to you guys is you go
here and then you go here and then you
feel them pushing on you to get this
little if you keep the movement going
whoa
when I shift my weight which a lot of
you are not doing that's how I get on
the other side of it so when I go like
this I'm not on that side of it stay
there
alright here's a plank I'm on this side
of the plane in order for me to not hold
him I have to be on that side of that
point so that's when I shift do you see
but now on the other side of the plane
you see that that's also when I
establish my single pivot point boom
there it is this foots not doing
anything now I'm not double pivoting
here I'm on single and this foot just
steps into the in space that I
[Music]
ships that they keep the smile
ironically and instead I just go in
you're not pulling the person so you
should feel where to go it's effort it's
effortless you should feel that his
fingers are there just wait so you don't
go there okay thinking here's a conflict
and I'm going to neutralize all that
energy wool